hey guys it is a sixteenth of September
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games but news let's talk about
the game things first up if you
pre-ordered yourself an iphone 6 then
you're partly responsible for Apple
breaking a pre-order record more than 4
million of the buggers have been ordered
between the iphone 6 and the gigantic
iphone 6 plus in the first 24 hours the
phones officially go on sale this friday
across 10 countries with another 20
following a week after that that does
mean that demand for the things has
exceeded current supply according to
Apple in comparison the iphone 5s
initial pre-order numbers will half that
of these new phones if you're looking
for more to do in destiny you'll
probably be interested in the fact that
the first six player raid has gone live
the raid challenge named a vault of
glass isn't for the faint of heart
developer Bungie have called it the most
elaborate mission ever created by us and
your character is going to need to be
level 26 or higher just to access it the
raid also requires six players to form a
group and join simultaneously so have
you been relying on matchmaking this one
won't work out for you Bungie have said
that vault of glass is a puzzle and a
gauntlet and the players who have enough
cunning on top of their surely skills
are in the best position to succeed said
cunning and skillful players apparently
made up prime God the first clan to
successfully complete the raid call of
duty advanced warfare has been coming
under fire from people who think it's a
little too tight and poorly the
accusations over the similarities like
advanced warfare future focus and
presence of mex first started back in
May when the game was revealed now
develop a sledgehammer have replied to a
tweet which blatantly said no matter how
hard you try and try people will always
be convinced at advanced warfare is a
ripoff of titanfall in response
sledgehammer co-founder Michael condry
said that he isn't worried about it and
the game will speak for itself when it
comes out this November ask your
question of the day let me know if you
think call of duty advanced warfare
looks like titanfall and if you're
in games need to differentiate
themselves from other titles that is it
from me today if you're after more newsy
things you can find stories on WWE 2k15
getting delayed and Forza horizon 2 DLC
on site I will catch you tomorrow